okay now see here's a good example of a  plant that you can't eat see all the  spikes so two things one it's poisonous  and two it would hurt the parks  department has so many programs Jerry is  in charge of our preteen nature hikes  for a while it was a teenage nature hike  but then we changed it because a girl  got pregnant look what we have here  country honey suckle Pawnee style yeah  take a look at that it's pretty and it  smells good great oh that's bear what  they don't need it oh why did you let me  eat that I never told you to eat that Oh  God let's see the animals no you don't  eat the country honeysuckle okay now  you'll have to throw that away let's not  scare him okay all right all right  we can eat Jerry is a very sweet and  smooth taste though  you